und mir zugeschaltet ist jetzt bild vize
paul ronzheimer der jetzt live in kiew
mit vitali klitschko sprich den
bürgermeister der stadt
vielen dank ich stehe mit vitali
klitschko wieder die die russische armee
hat angekündigt dass man die truppen
reduzieren will es wird interpretiert
dass man möglicherweise aus kiew
abziehen könnte hat die ukraine in kiew
den krieg bereits gewonnen
gar nicht sagen weil heute ab morgen der
ganze tag ihren bisher seine schlagworte
um eine satellitenstadt boveri dort eine
riesige explosion dass es eine wonne
man hört sogar in stadtmitte
deswegen gehe aber nicht an russische
regierung weil die hat schon im 19 94
versprochen
unsere unabhängigkeit und
integrität als cabrio sei atomwaffen
abgegeben nachdem lackiert creme des
logos und heute eher einen krieg geführt
weswegen hat sehr viel versprochen aber
trotzdem seine wird nicht nicht gehalten
zumal das zum zweites ziel war dass es
kein geheimnis hauptstadt und deswegen
von anfang an dich hatte in drei maximal
vier tage hat gewünscht
die stadt zu haben zu besetzen unsere
soldaten hat richtige gute antwort
gegeben und ein
mythos so gehört eine
stärkt der armen der welt voll trainiert
der user hat versucht schon zigmal
nachgehe zu kommen zu ihr eine eine
rundum gesund ich hab nie geschafft
danke für unsre patrioten hat
pläne
poliert und jetzt die sprecher mehr
möglich
neben man kann sagen das ist ein absolut
teilabzug ich weiß nicht wie lass uns
noch mal über die aktuelle situation
sprechen also während es dort
verhandlung gab in istanbul und der
russische verhandler dort gesagt hat
dass man bereit seid truppen abzuziehen
als kiew als vertrauensbildende maßnahme
gab es hier recht heftige kämpfe richtig
gibt um tief in die grenze liefern
richtige kämpfe das ist dort hier eine
art
telefonats vision begann also von
frieden noch nicht zu spüren dennoch
diese ankündigung von russland bedeutet
dass am ende auch dass man überrascht
von dem widerstand den es hier aus kehrt
gab von der stadt von den zivilisten
aber auch von den soldaten waren nicht
überrascht wie weit die war geschockt
weil keiner hat erwartet man eigentlich
keine katar wartet noch eine chemie kam
richtig hier gute antwort zu geben agca
das waren ja auch internationale staaten
die euch gesagt haben teilweise den
botschaft dann gesagt haben das wäre
eine frage von tagen bis deine stadt du
bist bürgermeister hier bist wie
angenommen würde ich habe darüber
gesprochen und habe ich schon zigmal
gesagt und wirklich noch einmal
wiederholen berufssoldaten werden
niemals in unserer stadt sein wir sind
bereit bereit unsere stadt zu
verteidigen unsere häuser zur
verteidigung seiner familie zu schützen
und deswegen die pläne wird niemals für
werden wir niemals
aufgeben stehen wie geht es in kiew
jetzt weiter was ist eine hoffnung
nehmen wir an es wird tatsächlich
dadurch dass die ukrainische armee ihre
pin zum beispiel teilweise zurück
erobert hat und auch jetzt um bravery
und andere vororte kämpft nehmen wir
alles würde ruhiger gibt es dann eine
normalisierung hier in der stadt oder
erstmal davon weit entfernt
teilweise legalisierung man kann nie
gesagt
jeden tag sterben unsere zivilisten
sterben unsere soldaten wickeln sagen
normalisierung wenn hier der russische
soldat kommt raus von unserem land
danken wir der normalisierung zu
sprechen hier im moment jeden tag
sterben zivilisten jeden tag sterben
ukraine und jeden tag
sogar eine neue nachrichten die
bürgermeister von
kristin dass eine kleine stadt entführt
worden und gibt kidnappt man kann so
sagen und keiner weise bescheid dass es
noch sehr viele bürgermeister wieder
auch wir wieder gedeckt von unsere
städte dass es man kann man kann nicht
so sein normalisieren harmonisiert
werden kann unsere kinder zur schule
gehen zum kindergarten wenn sie kommen
das ist ja unmöglich erklärt das
jetzt im moment jetzt im moment ist viel
ruhiger wir haben gestern noch viele
explosionen eine riesige explosion
gehört habe so foto recherchiert das war
keine explosionen das land
keine unsere gebäude getroffen und
unsere luft schützen ich hab gesagt der
raketen abgeschossen
gott sei dank ist in luft explodiert
nicht zusammen boden und kann ist
gestorben wie schätzt du wladimir putins
taktik jetzt ein es gibt leute die sagen
er hat sich verkalkuliert deswegen
braucht es jetzt einen teilrückzug
richtung osten wo er mario pohl
einnehmen will eine landverbindung
erstellen will und von vorher aus dann
wieder ziert anhalten können man kann
nämlich kalkulieren weil er
ich würde einfach sagen das ist
etwas wenn jemand so etwas macht dass
psychisch ungesund weil er tausende von
menschen sterben und die frage für was
wie so eine idee eine
politische oder russische reich zu
machen dass es das kommt nicht der
normale normale
menschliche
sehen das ist
sinnlose krieg und
gute versucht seine sein gesicht zu
verlieren und deswegen sieht der chef
nicht die hauptstadt so zu besetzen und
deswegen versucht jetzt die neue
strategie zu entwickeln welche strategie
wissen wir noch nicht
34 tage krieg auch für dich auf wladimir
wenn du jetzt mal zurückschauen mehr als
einen monat mittlerweile was hat das
auch mit euch gemacht
dass das sehen sie liegen in
militäruniform hier und die stadt ist
leer die dass es ein drama für jede von
440 millionen
anwohner unsere das waren das 40
millionen bürger
ist keine normale leben ist unsere
wirtschaft und unsere musik sondern
jetzt unsere lebens repariert wie hält
man das psychisch aus psychisch ist
ziemlich schwierig zu hören dass es sehr
ähneln die war auf einem tag um nach die
leute verbringen daher unter der erde in
bunkers die genetik indische gehen nicht
eine schule das ist eine millionen von
flüchtlingen durch eine dass es die
leben ist
man kann nicht so
vorstellen dass so etwas kann in unserem
land wirklich gewann passiert wenn wir
jetzt darauf schauen was die nächsten
tage in der nächsten woche um die
nächsten monate passiert und auch auf
deutschland schauen da gibt es ja immer
wieder die forderung dass die ukraine
mehr waffen braucht wie ist da der
aktuelle stand
wir brauchen waffen wir brauchen ich
möchte bisherigen beteiligungs waffen
weil wir greifen
und hinten und wir verteidigen möchte
ich so auch sagen das ist jeder muss
gestehen die vielseitigen nicht nur
unseres land unserer städte wir
verteidigen unsere werte und prinzipien
und ich hoffe genau das gleiche
prinzipien und werte was haben wir in
europa und deswegen gerne genau sagen
wie verteidigung auch europäische werte
und lehre in europa weil wir wissen
nicht wie weiterlaufen die display wie
kann man schon von krepl viele stimmen
gehört dass es bald lernt er muss sie
dann in eine russische reich zu kommen
und wie weit die pläne auf und bohren
oder bis zum deutschland oder ehemalige
ddr wieder aufzubauen und welche waffen
geht es nun kritisch ist noch hinter
deutschland ja einige wir brauchen halt
die arten brauchen eine renaissance
die luft schutz und dass die raketen
muss die raketen russische flugzeuge
mussten nicht unsere städte bombardiere
zum abschluss vitali klitschko du hast
deine familie in deutschland dann
glaubst du wirst du das erste mal wieder
die ukraine oder kiew verlassen können
wie lange wird dieser krieg noch da
sehr viele experten diskutieren darüber
und keine kann richtige antwort zu geben
dass es die grieg york am boden wände
russ und
geht raus von unserer
das kann noch wochen da und das kann
monate
experten sagen wir hoffen dass es die
krieg wird schnell wie möglich gewesen
aber das ist von uns abhängt dass nicht
die einzigste was hin von uns ab das ist
eine gegenstand gegen russische armee
und wir mussten unser land italien
dennoch wird ja darüber gesprochen über
vermeintliche kompromisse die die
ukraine eingehen könnte wurde darüber
gesprochen dass man zum beispiel mehrere
jahre nicht mehr über die krim spricht
also dass das de facto russisch wäre
dann oder darüber spricht über eine
neutralität oder über den dom bass was
ist aus deiner sicht ein komponist der
russische armee angegriffen ukraine hat
tausende von menschen umgebracht die hat
ganze wirtschaft eine ganze land tun hat
und jetzt wie sprechen berg am präriesee
einen teil von unserem land will muss
man an russland abgeben das ist eine
kampagne
von russischer seite
von russischen blick kann sein aber
davon unsere blick dass es die adresse
kommt und sagt wir spaltung im land ab
und dann wird eine kampagne von für die
aber für uns keine kompromisse waren
jeder russische seite geht raus dann
können wir diese diskussion und darüber
sprechen ob ihr kompanie
sogenannte komprimierte jetzt ein moment
wir mussten
krieg stoppen
schwieriger schwierige aufgabe hat
unsere regierung
zu besprechen und die die punkte
diskussionspunkte zu finden eine
russische
delegation wer spricht über mögliche
frieden
aber die einst
großen gang raus foto rheine das ist die
nach außen sondern auch
das wetter so reinigt territorium creme
das war auch die das ist eine stete und
dass es seine
das war eine lüge was
verbreitet russland wegen geschichte
wegen direktorium und unsere
territoriale integrität steht auch für
führungsämter stelle was erwartest du
für die nacht in den nächsten tage in
kiew gibt es die rochen und das ist
ruhiger wird
hoffen die hoffentlich nicht serien
nicht mehr ich hoffe dass es wird unsere
unsere
gebäude unserer schule wirklich nicht
mehr bombardiert und hoffen wir unsere
bürger wird nicht mehr sterben als sie
dann vitali klitschko befassen zusammen
wichtig zu sagen während sozusagen
russland angekündigt hat dass es ein
einteiler abzugeben soll gibt es hier in
den vororten weiter heftige kämpfe
vitali klitschko der bürgermeister hofft
aber dass es weniger wird aber damit
zurück nach berlin herzlichen dank
vielen dank auch an dich paul und bei
mir im studio ist jetzt bild
chefreporter peter tiede und
zugeschaltet ist auch noch bild meinung
chef philippe pare topf der eben auch
aus lemberg aus der ukraine berichtet
peter trotzdem die erste frage an dich
wie schätzt du die lage in kiew jetzt
gerade ein wir haben es gerade von
vitali klitschko gehört er sagt wir
hoffen dass der krieg ebenso schnell wie
möglich ändern wird wie es da eine
einschätzung also gehen wir mal nicht so
viel auf die verhandlung was ich
bemerkenswert fand war jetzt vitali
klitschkos ganz klare aussage dass es
keinen kompromiss
überblick territorien geben kann und
dass für ihn fest steht dass jeder
russische soldat ukrainischen boot
verlassen muss inklusive don was und
krim das heißt da steht er etwas anders
oder er sieht es härter als präsident
selensky das findet die bemerkenswerte
aussage und ich kann sie nachvollziehen
aber das war für mich jetzt wirklich
bemerkenswert und zu der lage in kiew
muss man einfach festhalten dass so
lange wie die russischen soldaten nicht
auch weg sind kann man den russen auch
nicht glauben und man kann auch nicht
einfach darauf vertrauen dass sie
tatsächlich jetzt tatsächlich ein
rückzug antreten und sich nur auf dem
don bosco zentrieren das muss man heftig
in frage stellen oder philipp
absolut und auch was tun bemerkenswert
fandest das wird auch glaube ich die
große konfliktlinie sein der nächsten
monate vielleicht sogar jahre wo bleiben
die russen wenn dieser krieg oder dieser
abschnitt des krieges vorbei sein wird
wenn man es russland zugesteht im
donbass zu bleiben ein teil des don was
de facto zu behalten dann schafft man
sozusagen ein neues regelwerk und europa
und das lautet greif ein land an tötete
zivilisten tötete soldaten und erhalte
einen teil davon wenn frank walter
steinmeier unser außenminister wäre wäre
das vermutlich seine präferierte lösung
also einfach noch mal das was er 2014
gemacht hat hier nochmal implementieren
aber das darf es natürlich nicht sein
man darf dass russland nicht zugestehen
langfristig den bass zu kontrollieren
wenn man nur mit hilfe eines
angriffskrieges überhaupt bekommen hat
aber wie realistisch philipp findest du
das denn also man hat sich ja fast daran
gewöhnt dass diese rebellen republiken
diese komischen selbsternannten da
hinten die russischen dann jetzt und nur
ans existieren und dass die krim bei
russland wir haben immer gesagt das ist
ukrainisch wir haben uns auch genauso
genauso verhalten ich bin immer brav
über die ukraine eingereist juni war
russland aber wie realistisch ist das
dass die ukraine das tatsächlich
zurückkämpfen kann entweder im felde
oder am verhandlungstisch
ich glaube die ukraine wird sich damit
arrangieren müssen dass die krim
mittelfristig auf jeden fall vielleicht
sogar langfristig großes bleibt das
gleiche kann sogar gelten für die
sogenannten teilrepubliken wie sie
bestanden vor russland die ukraine
überfallen hat also vor dem 24 februar
über diesen status zu sprechen darüber
sind glaube ich viele menschen in der
ukraine bereit
man darf es eben russland oder zumindest
sehen das sehr viele kleine so man darf
ist russland nicht zugestehen dass sie
über diese
teile republiken sogenannten teil der
republiken hinaus gebiete behalten die
sie erst im laufe des überfalls erobert
haben hätte eine frage noch an dich gibt
es denn im moment dann hoffnung also
kann man überhaupt jetzt von hoffnung
wirklich sprechen nein ganz klar nein
weil wenn man selbst vier von sechs
punkten wie das jetzt aus der türkei ist
von von den verhandlungen weniger einig
sind heißt es dass zwei und da sind halt
die großen brocken nicht da eigentlich
so dazugehört hat unter anderem die
teilung der ukraine die wladimir putin
ganz klar will und wir dürfen nicht
vergessen er hat in seiner ansprache am
20 februar dieses jahres ein paar tage
vor kriegsbeginn bevor diesen erneuten
krieg angefangen hat ganz klar der
ukraine das existenzrecht und die
staatlichkeit abgesprochen will die
ukraine von der landkarte als staat
tätigen und wenn einen kleinen rest
übrig lassen der meinetwegen nach polen
kann oder der sich noch ukraine nennen
darf aber dann nicht mehr die alte
ukraine ist und daran wird er festhalten
und daran muss er sich tatsächlich auf
seinen eigenen russen ja dann auch
tatsächlich messen lassen weil er kann
nicht zurück kommen und sagen ich habe
mario pohl geworden und das war dann der
pokal und dafür sind dann 40 50 60
tausend russische soldaten gestorben das
wird nicht funktionieren
ich finde meine frage noch an dich du
bericht ist ja schon seit wochen eben
aus lemberg eben auch aus der ukraine
wie ist denn jetzt die lage heute dort
vor ort haben es vorhin von paul
ronzheimer gehört in kiew er hat immer
noch bomben gehört und einschläge gehört
wie ist es bei dir am
berg hatten wir heute mehrfach luftalarm
aber das ist hier fast jeden tag so die
frage ist nur passiert etwas oder nicht
und da ist die antwort ein ganz klares
nein seiten samstag seitdem wirklich
großen raketenangriff einmal auf ein öl
depot und einmal auf eine militärische
infrastruktur wie das hier gesagt wurde
ist es bislang ruhig geblieben das heißt
die west ukraine und insgesamt lemberg
bleibt weiterhin sozusagen ruhigste die
sicherste oase der ukraine und für viele
menschen ist es tatsächlich auch eine
oase denn hier sind mehrere
hunderttausend flüchtlinge die
natürliche sehr hoffen dass es hier in
lemberg nicht genau so sein wird wie das
was sie im osten erlebt haben trafen
mario pohl oder in kiel philipp wenn du
jetzt hörst dass sich die russen
zurückziehen wollen glaubst du einen
tatsächlichen rückzug aus kiew oder um
sie herum oder nur an einen taktischen
vorläufigen
ich glaube nur an einen taktischen
rückzug
denn es gibt keinen grund für optimismus
bei putin ich glaube wir menschen neigen
alle dazu zu optimismus immer zu hoffen
dass es doch noch gut werden kann aber
solange ein wahnsinniger im kreml sitzt
dann darf man das nicht man dafür muss
wirklich gegen diese gedanken an kämpfen
und wir hatten gestern groß auf bild.de
und auch in der zeitung berichtet über
die prognose des selensky beraters
alexia ristovic der diesen krieg den wir
jetzt gerade sehen 2009 10 bereits
vorhergesagt hat und er hat auch gesagt
es kann sein dass es mehrere kriege
geben wird zwei oder drei angriffskriege
russlands auch das muss man im kopf
behalten deswegen gut dass jetzt
verhandelt wird wir hoffen alle dass es
bald einen waffenstillstand geben wird
aber damit ist die sache nicht gegessen
sondern putin wird wenn es diesmal nicht
schafft und es sieht so aus als würde er
es nicht schaffen wird er weiterhin
versuchen immer wieder mit neuen
überfällen die ukraine zu tun nicht
vielen dank erstmal an dich phillip
bleibt es ja für uns in lembeck und
bericht ist eben täglich auch über die
situation dort vor ort wir wollen einmal
nach odessa schauen dann auch dort ist
bild kollege sebastian bringe vor uns
für uns vor ort in der ukraine
hallo sebastian du bist an der
küstenstadt odessa und wir haben in den
vergangenen tagen immer wieder darüber
berichtet dass auch dort angriffe der
russen erwartet werden wie ist denn die
lage da jetzt heute vor ort
akira es wurde viel darüber geredet und
deshalb sollte das nächste große ziel
von vladimir putin werden und jetzt
sieht es so aus als würde sich die lage
hier entspannen und maßgeblich
entscheidend dafür ist das was an der
front in nicolai passiert dass seine
stadt 140 kilometer von hier entfernt da
gelang den russen der durchbruch nicht
und ohne diese truppen da ist ein
angriff auf und des relativ sinnlos und
jetzt ist es sogar so dass die russen
aus mikolaj vertrieben worden sind sie
sind jetzt wieder 15 kilometer außerhalb
der stadt dazu muss man sagen die
landungsschiffe die lange hier vor der
küste gelegen haben die sind auch weg
eine amphibische landung du jetzt auch
gar keinen sinn machen der strand ist
familien das wasser ist verdient und
noch dazu hatte oder sei in den letzten
vier wochen wirklich sehr viel zeit sich
auf diesen andere vorzubereiten die
stadt ist die reinste festung es gibt
hier sehr viel luftabwehr also auch mit
hubschraubern
könnte putin wahrscheinlich nicht
genügend truppen hier reinbringen
deshalb sieht es aktuell so aus als
würde sich die lage hier entspannen und
ein angriff ist wohl erst mal ich sage
das mit größter vorsicht vom tisch
jesus denn vor ort sind überhaupt noch
menschen dort oder sind schon die
meisten auch aus dieser stadt geflüchtet
also die situation ist so wer fliehen
konnte der hat es getan es sind
natürlich in erster linie frauen und
kinder die über die nahe gelegenen
grenze nach moldawien und rumänien
geflohen sind und die die noch da sind
die sind bereit zu kämpfen die wollen
ihre stadt nicht kampflos hergeben die
wind dazu bereit dem dem feind ins
gesicht zu sehen das merkt man hier an
jeder ecke putin hat lange versucht den
willen der menschen zu brechen er wollte
mit ständigem luftalarm angst und
schrecken verbreiten das ist ihm nicht
gelungen das gegenteil ist der fall die
menschen die sind hier immer näher
zusammengerückt vielen dank sebastian
bringe auch du bleibst für uns ja
weiterhin vor ort und berichtet ist eben
über die aktuellen geschehnisse aus der
ukraine